[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's a new week in fortnight so once
again it's time to meet up and go
through all the map changes and update
our theory
for the overarching storyline to the
season this week's poll is in the top
corner now
what will be the hidden skin for the
season the unlockable skin
i have a feeling it's going to be a
female visitor or maybe a female version
of the enforcer but what do you think
week 3 of season x has brought us many
changes and things to think about so
relax for 10 minutes
use code adamaru in the fortnite shop
and help me get to 1 million subscribers
before 2019 ends
and in return i shall show you my
minging face
oh and one more thing if you have an
enforcer skin please stay until the end
i need your help with a new video
anyway enough chit chat let's do this
[Music]
without a doubt the biggest news of the
week is the return of the fiends
those zombies those husks they keep
trying to bring them back and people
keep on hating them
personally i i quite like them because i
quite like save the world too but what
about you
well over in mega mall the poi has
reverted back to retail row
if you remember at the back end of
season 8 retail roll was decimated by a
lava attack from the volcano
and then when season nine began the
whole thing became the mega mall
but right now for a few weeks at least
the og retail roll
returns the nom nom sign is back which
was transported to above wailing woods
back in season
four and remember the food war well
there's no sign of it here there's no
tomato town there's no pizza pit here
this
is from season one no food war in sight
but maybe that will change
in the weeks to come the best thing in
my eyes it's simple
it's this
the oversized visual man i love that
thing if you dance with him did you know
that you will win every single game you
play
it's true it's true check the comments
people will tell you it's true you dance
with the fish
you win the game
[Music]
there's now a weekly pattern in place a
rift beacon aka a flux capacitor was set
up in the center of town pointing
towards loot lake
and that broken energy source we call
the orb and always remember the person
we have to thank for that
is mecca teddy and singularity cheers
love once the beacon was switched on
energy was pulled from the orb and
powered the rift shard
shooting a bolt of time bending energy
into the sky taking us back to the old
days of retail row
the only problem is though those pesky
fiends have come with it too
hey look early face reveal this is what
i look like i look like a
pink tan zombie true story bro
there is something more impactful though
we should be paying attention to this
week
when the meteor was frozen in place did
you notice any cracks
because i didn't well check back again
at the end of week two
and these small cracks have begun to
form all around this giant
meatball each day a tiny crack appears
and a little blue light becomes more
powerful
i hate to say it but whatever is holding
that asteroid in place
won't be able to do that forever this
thing is either going to plummet to the
ground
destroying factories once again or it
will explode in mid-air
let's make sure we add this to the
cinematic we do at the end of the video
i'm sorry to say this yet again there is
no progress in hut watch
whoever is building this monstrosity has
had more days off than
your mum
the pink flowered area around the polar
peak monsters corpse continues to grow
and engulf the skeleton
completely off topic here but i thought
the bones looked a bit aggressive
and decided to remove all the teeth and
now it looks like a granny
how much better is that also when you
look down on the skeleton do you see a
butterfly shape
i can't decide what the heck i see here
is it just random swirls
or is this a nod to the butterfly event
in fact on my travels nothing really has
changed this week the return of risky
reels
it's it's the same the golf shack at the
lagoon no change at all not even the
weird rooted house seems to have changed
but then i saw this
our lord and savior kevin the cube has
now been immortalized with the memorial
in the desert
i paid my respects and remembered when
he appeared all those seasons ago we
would stand and wait for each of the
cacti to be destroyed
wow those were the days just in case you
weren't up to date on this over time a
set of cactuses
or cacti whichever you prefer were hit
with bolts of lightning
counting down to something then this
happened
kevin was born and since that day that
spot hasn't changed
until now his birthplace is forever
marked forever immortalized
shame about where he died though i'll
never forget that tear he dropped
rest in peace brother here's another
epic update for the sweats of the world
the people who get their kicks from
being the best
box fighters in the world both the duos
and solo fortnite world cups can be
found in game
over in lucky landings it's the solo
champ booger
who seems to be named after some mucus
and over in the snow biome you can find
the duos champions cup
i know i joke but you must admit this is
a great touch by fortnight
by the way did you know that all the
winners at that event had to pay almost
half their winnings
to the state of new york in tax so
buga's 3 million becomes something like
1.5 million after deductions
still a good day's work oh here's a
little change of pace
have you seen next week's loading screen
yet a possible rift seems to be here now
and if the loading screen is correct
it is strong enough to rift items such
as a triceratops
and drop them on other people how insane
could that be to drop an entire building
on someone
i wonder what ali a will use this on
first
there's a diplodocus dude that joke
never gets old
let's get back over to dusty have you
kept an eye on the small updates over
the first few weeks
let's quickly recap within a day of
dusty returning one of the containers
was ransacked
items thrown out chucked away slowly a
makeshift control center was created
with satellite surveillance on top and a
mixture
of new and old tech inside a piece of
the meteor was spotted
it vanished quickly but it linked the
spot back to the visitor
and this week it was confirmed that the
flux capacitors aka the
shard beacons were created in this very
spot
i originally thought the government you
know those men in black were responsible
for the rift beacons
as sort of a defense mechanism but oh no
no i was completely wrong
from all the evidence shown it's the
visitor who is creating the beacons
and to compound this further look at the
shape and colour of a functioning beacon
it's the same shape as the visor and the
red and black color scheme
of that visitor i didn't make the
connection last week but so many of you
did in the comments so thank you very
much for helping me out
and being part of this community you are
freaking awesome
okay now's the time to put everything
together here's the story of season x as
the grenade community see it
and remember if you think this is wrong
write in the comments what you think the
story is and i will act it out next week
let's do this
[Music]
as season x approaches a rift in time
and space
causes a temporal void to open between
dimensions
the asteroid propels towards the island
but instead of leaving devastation
a mystical power holds the rock in place
inside the meteor the visitor awakes
but is he friend or foe he quickly
analyzes the area and sets up a base
in the dusty containers he slowly
upgrades all his equipment using his
extraterrestrial knowledge
and technology from around the island
harnessing the power of the meteor
as a time traveler he understands how to
bend time and space
setting up rift beacons around the
island his first attempt over in tilted
went so far back in time
it was a failure not put off by this he
continues working his second attempt at
the mega mall
was more successful taking a portion of
the island back two years
instead of 200 years but he encountered
another problem
the horde the husks of the dead caught
in time and space
with this failure he continues working
towards his end goal
protecting the island from the meteor
hitting but another problem occurs
the meteor is cracking if it explodes
where it is he will be killed along with
everyone else on the island
so the visitor goes back to work can he
save the island
in time i don't know about you but that
sounds pretty epic to me
what do you think are you on board with
this theory or shall we change it up in
the future
thank you to everyone who's contributed
to this story but i personally think the
visitor is trying to run away from the
enforcers
i'd love to see that in your story ideas
this week please also if you have an
enforcer skin
i need you for a video please join our
discord the link is in the description
and send a screenshot of your lobby
screen
with you wearing the enforcer skin and
i'll give you a secret rank in our
discord and you'll be in a secret video
later this week
okay so there we have it what have i
missed please let me know and spread the
word i'm trying to get to one million
subs
before i go these people on screen are
my heroes they've used code adamarro in
the fortnite shop thank you so much
if you want to be immortalized like
these legends i'll put the details in
the description below
okay right we're done and dusted i'm
going to find the architect of hot watch
and figure out what's going on down
there i'll be back on tuesday with more
map updates i'm adam from playstation
grenade come talk to me on twitter i'm
adam grenade over there
it's been a pleasure see you next time